il fauche mans j'ai été très blessée
parce que j'ai toujours été fan d'elle
et j'adore ces émissions et je les ai
toujours dit et j'ai un peu touché home
est la chouchoute hier dans le gogo si
pour vous parler de gad elmaleh qui sera
le prochain invité d'une ambition intime
avec karine le marchand
il c'est vrai qu'ils avaient l'air voilà
de bien s'entendre sur la bande annonce
bien sûr on n'a jamais dit qu'il est
temps sont ils sont super pote c'est ce
qu'ont à dire
visiblement karine le marchand n'a pas
trop kiffé le débat je vais vous dire
dans un instant ce cas-là hosties cet
après-midi sur les réseaux sociaux
mais d'abord on regarde ce que vous avez
dit kelly et mathieu et je vous dis
qu'on voyait un truc vois ça je vous le
dis tout le temps que dg là c'était
extrêmement sympathique faut que je
digère pas où est le mal et karine là
elle est montée dans les tours
je vais lui répondre dans un instant
assez planté et elle va se planter aussi
ça s'appelle fréquence du cancer a
marché c'est vrai qu'en ce temps on s'en
fout la thèse du box a pas marché non
plus je tiens on peut parler un petit
peu d'amour sur ce plateau a passé ses
nerfs et l'on parlait pas de ça on
parlera alors attachement voulue par les
cornes
mais moi je voulais vous dire que juste
une chose gabbert elle passe à cames
c'est sûr qu'à côté sur un 100 % el alem
les choses passionnel le legends
sulfureux
il est trop propre il est beaucoup trop
lisse il a les yeux bleus il à la police
fin c'est bon ça n'ira pas mais ma
musique c'est miss a accédé à l'habitude
un mail à djerba il dit alors karine
lemarchand jeune attaquant je vais dire
ça répond s'il vous plaît tu dire ça
répond parce que juste avant ça
justement ça j'ai dit son émission est
super il faudra faire quelques numéros
seulement parce qu'elle a sur lui une
super émission de la tuerie alors on a
toujours été très sympathique et kadri
sur vidas et l'acsi d'ashish pascal doit
tenir buzz en ce moment car une marche
les réseaux sociaux ont donné le droit à
la parole à des légions d'imbéciles qui
avant de parler qu'au bar après un verre
de vin et ne causait aucun tort à
l'affectivité où les faisait taire tout
de suite alors qu'aujourd'hui ils ont
même ils ont le même droit de parole
qu'un prix nobel c'est l'invasion des
imbéciles alors traité d'imbécile que
des lives et dvd matthieu delormeau
pour les connaître un petit peu karine
et pour connaître un peu ils sont
beaucoup plus intelligents toi déjà une
chose me dit voilà donc voilà donc moi
je prends toujours est toujours la
défense de mes chroniqueurs déjà je
trouve que c'est c'est complètement
démesuré ta réponse mois là de dire que
c'est des imbéciles alors qu'ils ont
rien et surtout à quel item depuis des
années
j'adore elle te défends toujours là le
donnait juste une analyse et puis tu
vois pas ne t'a pas insulter elle n'a
pas insulté ta famille elle a rien dit à
lady diana lady jusqu'à d'après lt mais
les bad boys c'est pas une insulte voilà
matthieu delormeau il a dit que ton
émission était très bien mais que
ambitions intime fallon faire peu pour
que ça marche
et derrière je sais pas ce que tu as je
pense qu'il faut que tu prennes une
camomille calme un peu de taille un peu
dans les prés un sens l'amour est dans
le pré tout seul que tu marches un peu
dans le pré ce que tu te retrouve un peu
et quand tu seras talent mais quand tu
auras dégonfler voilà je te le dis tu
viendras nous voir sans aucun problème
pour l'instant c'est vraiment je pense
que c'est démesuré et je trouve que ça a
été très méchant ta réponse bas mais je
pense que ça a beaucoup blessé mathieu
équipe kelly franchement j'ai été très
blessée parce que j'ai toujours été fan
d'elle et j'adore ces émissions et je
les ai toujours dit et j'ai un peu
touché au mais la soutenons mais c'est
normal c'est très méprisant il faut que
c'est gratuit c'est méchant c'est pas du
tout ce qu'on veut faire ici non ici on
n'est jamais méchant et on n'aura jamais
méchants on veut rigoler plus on a donné
son avis on n'a jamais dit que tu étais
avec intel je dirais mais les bad boys
alors allez y et compense pour elle
c'est beau savoir de la télé riches et
des l'épreuve lagarde
[Applaudissements]
concert vraiment envie d'avoir un avis
mais c'est tout à fait ça elle veut pas
qu'on pensera le monde est là on rigole
on rigole avec les gens qui nous
regardent pas besoin de se distraire le
soir on va pas arriver là parler de
politique de truction on essaye de
tourner ça à la rigolade
là elle dit les réseaux sociaux
s'étaient pas sur un réseau social
c'était là déjà il a su que les gens des
réseaux sociaux est allé sur un stage
sur les réseaux sociaux
moi j'ai envie d'y renoncer la semaine
sainte en parlant je vais dire légende
et d'instinct elle vous a insulté
regardez bien mais ça c'est vocal
insultes alors alors on oublie de
situations double berthod et coup mais
on s'en fout
voilà c'est franchement c'est ainsi
qu'ils ont des couilles c'est le frère
de jean mermoz
oui alors je perds ce plateau justement
on rigole et tout ça il aurait fallu
qu'à répondre avec humour et naturel
beaucoup mieux passé je dis rien quand
je pense que vous avez voulu me caser
avec elle je lui lécher les pieds avec
matin le traitent d'imbécile
merci aux stéphanois mais c'est vrai que
je le dis à tout le monde vous pouvez
critiquer les chroniqueurs je serai
toujours de leur côté et je les
défendrai toujours et que vous ne croyez
pas quand vous critiquez les
chroniqueurs vous vous m'attaquez aussi
parce que je sais qu'il y en a qui ont
pas voilà le courage de dire les choses
ne me dire les choses directement qu'ils
disent oui mais c'est les chroniqueurs
sachez que les chroniqueurs et moi c'est
la même passé paris voilà je vous dis
donc si vous critiquez un chroniqueur
vont critique également tu vois là deux
salles deux ambiances kev adams ont fait
la vanne quand tu te mets là c'est
étonnant d'abord merci beaucoup pour la
défense de ne devoir et avec autant de
2,2 bas 2 de sa série faveur après après
je crois pour prendre sa défense à l
aller j'avais partie de ces gens à mon
avis qui n'ont pas regardé l'émission
c'est ce que vous savez que j'aurai un
conte pour vous dire vu ce qu'ils ont
dit oui de shova et de raconter un truc
bizarre hills a résulté des amis si elle
avait vu l'émission ça va bien ça aussi
de faire un truc de marquer un truc que
si méchant alors que kelly était toute
mignonne en disant lemon boys et les
jolies et moi jle et son émission et hop
ok encore deux trois conquis lui ont dit
on sait tous que je donnerais comme
message c'est regarder la télévision et
puis après tu commentes vincent
c'est évidemment me cherche pas non plus
qu est-ce qui a droit valait mieux
qu'elle voit là et quel sera d excuser
[Musique]